okay what did you do to my Walgreens
card good morning Henry there's a zero
balance on my Walgreens card all my
Amtrak rewards points are gone I can't
even use my MCI calling card you hacked
me didn't you
you hacked me like I'm some kind of
journalist ready for a truce truce I
called in my friend from the Public
Works Department and asked him to pull
your toilet water sample toilet water
sample sample of your toilet water you
know what I found in there MS winters
traces of THC that's marijuana reefer
jazz cigarettes herb 4/20 the sticky
icky the kind bud yeah the gin and tonic
that's cockney slang for the chronic do
you know what I'm talking about his
winters yes hookah fuel okay
spider-man's girlfriend Mary Jane Watson
what's your point God doesn't make
mistakes but you do drug use is grounds
for termination what do you want I want
to work on whatever your secret project
is fine but don't tell anyone I told you
it's a computer virus from North Korea
right are we for it or against it do you
even know anything about computer
viruses of course I know they have to do
with computers I don't have time to
teach you about viruses and
cybersecurity I need to work on stopping
this thing all right not to worry I'll
just send your bong water pee to the
Undersecretary of firing your ass okay
okay okay you can help and you'll give
me full credit if we stop the virus no
way yes way I bet there's a set of steak
knives whoever cracks it so I'm gonna do
all the work and you're gonna get all
the glory well now you know how I felt
about Oliver North taking all the credit
for around contra that was my baby and
that guy gets to Fox TV shows out of it
well you're gonna have to pitch in
somehow don't worry I'll be a great
asset to this project I've been reading
up I already know that Trojan horse
digital worms can go fishing and set up
honey pots and PCs basically it's a
bunch of dr. Susan by the way
you know dr. Seuss not a real doctor
never had a medical license but he did
have a license to kill on my orders
he killed Jim Morrison for me oh and
that way we know Jim Morrison isn't
behind this North Korean virus see I'm
already helping who's Jim Morrison